is it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should a mass
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV is
the only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry and
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
that on TV on radio
and on your smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight p on S A backlash for the NHS
GP whose movement calls for Jihad and
denies the Hamas Massacre was a
terrorist a terrorist attack does he
really represent Muslim views is he fit
to practice medicine in this country
Richie's Rwanda plan passes its
parliamentary test but will it ever
actually work is it worth it can it save
his skin will
debate president zilinski is at the
White House Tonight with a powerful plea
for more Aid in his battle against
Vladimir Putin I'll take on the pundit
and the politi from the American
conservative right who both say Ukraine
shouldn't get another American
[Music]
set live from the news building in
London this is Pier Morgan uncensored
good evening welcome to Pi Morgan
uncensored Dr Abdul wahed is the leader
of a controversial islamist movement
which glorified the Hamas attacks and
chanted for Jihad on the Streets of
London astonishingly he's also an acting
serving long serving actually NHS GP and
last night he came on my show accepted
an invitation to be interviewed after he
was uh in the newspapers for his uh
thoughts about what happened October the
7th and well that interview caused last
night a bit of a stir do you think Hamas
are a terror group I believe it's a
resistance organization do you think
what they didn't October the 7th was a
terror attack I believe that if
civilians got killed on that day it is
it is appalling it is apping you're a
doctor man is apping you're a doctor in
you mean also believe 1200 people got
massacred well very clearly Dr W cast
out whether the atrocities on October
7th even took place also clearly
questioned whether any civilians had
been massacred he believes the Hamas
attacks were an act of resistance and
the people who did it are not terrorists
but they're fighting a resistance I
don't think they were 1,200 innocent
people were killed that day women were
raped babies and the yly were kidnapped
some people were beheaded it was a
medieval orgy of indiscriminate violence
and we know that in no small part
because Hamas filmed their attacks and
gleefully celebrated them in videos they
posted to the world and Hamas has since
publicly warned that it will not
hesitate to repeat the attacks
again
whatever your view of this war and I've
tried to platform a lot of people on
both sides of it repeatedly so we can
get a sense of what both sides are
thinking denying that the massacre of
October the 7th even happened cannot be
the basis for any sensible discussion I
have deep sympathy with the decades long
plight of the Palestinian people which
I've expressed many times I've
repeatedly called out Israel's
occupation of both Gaza and the West
Bank I've deep unease about the scale of
Israel's response to the Hamas attack
une ease that's now shared by the
president of the United States but to
deny that it was a terror attack at all
it's quite frankly poisonous delusion
and I think it's entirely valid to
question whether this man's views are
compatible with being an NHS doctor in a
publicly funded Health Service I'm not
calling for him to be fired or cancelled
as some I've said today I gave him a
platform on this show called uncensored
to elaborate on his opinions but I found
a lot of his answers deeply concerning
and I do believe many members of the
public not least his own patience might
also share my unease about the opinions
he so willingly offered just as they
were about cries of jihad on the Streets
of London there's been a backlash from
some Muslim followers of myself on
Twitter mostly because I suggested Dr
wahed wants women to be
oppressed reest would you like Sharia
law in this country last time I'm going
to ask if Sharia law if Sharia law or no
if Sharia law means upholding Family
Values means looking after the poor
means no gays no feminist are women who
get above them that's your caricature no
that's I know what Shar law wants why
why does so many women become Muslim
these days they want to be oppressed is
that what you're going to tell
me well I said that in the specific
context of Dr Wah's desire for Sharia
Laur this country and his defense of a
tweet from one of the members of his own
organization calling feminist and gay
people filth it's important to
understand that context I don't suggest
for a moment that women who want to
convert to Islam uh should do so for any
other than perfectly good reasons I have
no problem with Islam as a religion or
with Muslims I have a problem though
with people who endorse and support
terrorism or who are blatantly
homophobic or who are blatantly
misogynist now many people have since
accused me of being as I say anti-muslim
but I'm not no one who watches this show
could possibly reach that conclusion let
me be Crystal Clear again I'm
anti-terrorists and I'm anti- those who
support
terrorists well joining me now from
teleview is Douglas Murray the associate
spect
the co-founder of the Muslim debate
initiative Abdullah Al andalusi and Dr
iseline abues the Canadian Palestinian
Medical Doctor Who's joined me again in
the studio I'm great to see you thank
you very much indeed for joining me let
me start with you if I may Dr Abes um
when you saw that interview what was
your response to the fact that it's an
NHS doctor working and living in this
country who was saying those
things it's important I am coming you
know I heard it I heard many of your
interviews Jihad the word
Jihad my presence here is
Jihad when I'm coming to meet with you
to advocate for my Palestinian people
and for saving lives of the people is
Jad and this is the highest level of
jihad the
resistance against someone who is
invading you this is the lowest level of
jihad but Jihad when I am traveling when
I am going to any place even someone who
is dying because of far away from his
home is a kind of jihad when we are
fasting when we are working work is the
Jihad and that's the most important we
need to understand it not to take it out
of the context in The Limited
understanding of it when I am invaded
with the disease Co what do I do I have
to resist the co and that's when we Face
cancer disease any cancer with respect
you you would not categorize
October the 7th as a resistance it's you
know I condemn the killing of any
innocent human being and for me I was
born my daughters were killed before
October 7th I was born as a Palestinian
refugee before October 7 my parents were
refugees before 48 they were born in
Palestine so the history Didn't Start
The World Is Not created October 7th
that's what we need and we are today
it's important but let me let me let me
let me continue let me continue let me
continue please today is the 12th of
December today is the 12th of December
where we have more than 23 Palestinians
thousand are killed more than 45,000 are
severely wounded even the damage in the
Gaza Strip as Bor the representative of
Foreign Affairs in the European Union
it's far beyond the damage in Germany
for six years in two months more than
that so even you know how that's not
true actually why no no no there there
was far he he said that who said that
borell the representative of the
European Union the Foreign Affairs but
there far more people died in World War
II than have died no no the damage the
damage theal damage the destruction well
there certainly would have been more
damage in Germany in World War II he he
mentioned that himself you can that
won't be factually accurate but my
here's my question though for you it all
comes back to me I'm I'm very happy to
platform anybody on this show right to
the point where they try and convince me
that what happened on October 7th was
not an act of Terror and when people
refuse to concede that point I I find it
very hard then to have a civilized
discussion it's why I got so annoyed
last night well can
we the killing of my daughters as
terrorist well I think it was appalling
and I think you what do you consider it
as terrorist I I do not consider Israel
to be a terrorist organization what
the I think here's a question we have to
ask ourselves which is um since you have
defended um uh Israel's operation in
Gaza as
self-defense and since you have don't
misquote me don't misquote me I've
defend so you you don't say it's part of
their self-defense no let me clarify
okay I've defended Israel's right to
defend itself right in fact they have a
duty to its civilians after hamas's
repeated threats since October the 7th
to repeat it to defend so the is the war
not selfdefense
let me just clarify my position so you
know right however I have repeatedly
questioned the proportionality of
Israel's response as indeed their
greatest allies of not the response
itself do but not the response itself
though I think they're perfectly
entitled to go and take out okay so so
may may I continue my question then ask
you so since as I repeat so since you
have Justified their response maybe not
how they've carried it out exactly but
you justify their response of
self-defense their right to defend
themselves by taking out the terrorists
committed that atrocity yes
and and presumably you refused to call
Israel and you have refused when you've
haven't been asked to co Israel a
terrorist uh organization government or
the IDE terrorist organization the
difference is here here
weang let me finish my question please I
have a question for you I clarify you're
making some statement a bit misleading
sure this country considers Hamas to be
a prescribed terror group they do not
consider Israel to be a terrorist
organization and nor do I so that's the
position I'm not asking the United
States the United
I'm not asking the British government
I'm asking you peers I British
government isn't here I do not think
they're now let me finish my question if
I can ask the question as well right um
ask to discuss so considering that you
have Justified the operation uh that
Israel initiated a self-defense and that
you refuse to call Israel uh a ter a
terrorist organization or a terrorist
government the spite the fact that um as
many pal almost as many Palestinians
gazin have died in under Israel's
Precision bombing then as the as
londoners have died during the whole
year of the blitz under German bombing
which wasn't Precision bombing and yet
you still say that well Israel isn't a
terrorist organization I think the
question we should be asking here is
shouldn't you should you be suspended uh
is it responsible to have a person with
your views speaking to the public when
you clearly refused to uh condemn that
which needs to be condemned which was
worse the London Blitz that with
Precision weapons and the Germans didn't
even have Precision weapons perfectly
reasonable question yes and you've asked
me it on my show yes the fact you're
here and able to ask that I think is
evidence that I'm prepared to listen to
people who will look me in the eye and
ask me difficult questions well he not
going to say that but anyway that's fine
but that's fine you're perfectly
entitled to it we believe in uncens and
Free Speech here but let me ask you the
question then which I ask he's answering
my question but you haven't answered it
well I have I said I don't think they're
a terrorist organization despite the
fact that they've they've killed almost
as many question as Germans did when
they bombed London under the blitz for
one year non Precision bombs I have
given you an unequivocal answer now let
me ask you if you can give me one yes do
you believe Hamas are a terror
organization okay and I'd like to ask
you what what do no just answer my
question well I need I need
clarification well this country has
prescribed it as a terror group do you
think they are are you the British
government no to okay so I want you're
CL I want a clarification I gave you a
simple straight answer what does it mean
no you tell me I I don't know you're
asking me a question you ask question
you don't think they are a terror group
no I want I want your definition of
would you what is a terror group an act
that commits acts of Terror a group that
commits Terror attacks as they did on
October one that commits terror attack
all right fine so Define terror do you
want to answer question or not I do but
I just want clarification no no we all
know what Terror please no no we're
going to go somewhere with this we are
no we're going to go somewhere with this
right are you going to answer the
question yes once I get your definition
what's a terror attack the definition is
as is laid down in international law
it's committing Act of Terror which is
which is Terrorism are you asking
questions you don't know the definition
of well why don't you tell me what you
think it I don't know you're asking the
question you have no idea what terrorism
is no I want I want to answer your
question I would say massacring 12200
people on October the 7th in the way
Hamas did is an act of Terror do you
agree so so killing civilians is an act
of Terror no that's not what I said oh
so so then killing civr on that scale is
Terrorism so so killing civilians is not
an act of ter you're not going to answer
let me bring no I want I want your
definition I want you to be cons we have
a third guest I want to I want to I want
to say something all right you know
really you
know United States recognize blo as a
terrorist and it negotiates with blo
this is one thing the second October 7
happened and many things happened after
are we here just stuck there as a
snapshot and to discuss it or we want to
discuss what after and what can be done
way that's the most important I think
they're all important issues but right
now because of what happened in the
Fallout from last night's show I
specifically want to discuss the
definition of terrorism Hamas and
whether a
British
hang defition I'm going to bring I'm
going to bring in Douglas M you sitting
patiently here Douglas uh first of all
what was your reaction to this interview
with an NHS doctor last night on the
show well let me first of all say that
uh it's NE NE to clear quite a lot of
things up because we've heard quite a
lot of hogwash in the last few minutes
firstly uh your guest last night is a
member of an extremist organization
hisbah which is banned in many countries
including in European countries and it's
also banned in many Muslim countries
it's banned in Pakistan it's banned in
Egypt and that's because these Muslim
governments recognize that it is an
extremist group that has a revolutionary
ideology that wants to replace
government Muslim countries European as
well as in as do you know Germany one
European country is Bandon um Douglas Mo
I'm not going to let you lie to the
audience like you usually do you're
going to justify everything you say on
this show Murray right so please give me
one
country it's not b in Germany just
said you're not listening you're not
listening you're not listening to the
audience let Google it for yourself his
p in Germany are they banned as an
organization is this is is this Mr Al
andalusi can I just check cuz I can't
see you is that him yeah okay this is a
guy he's of no significance but he's a
guy who I have seen in studios for years
spouting extreme islamist rhetoric many
years ago he couldn't condemn the
killing of the journalist at Charlie
ABDO last year he wouldn't condemn the
attempted murder of salon rushi now he
can't do this he fails every
single let me get on to the question I'm
not going to engage I'm not going to
engage in a fight with this with this
islamist let me answer the question PE
put to me before you try to interrupt
again only if you don't lie let him
answer please first of all let him
answer please first of all I'm not going
to keep being talked over by this
islamist bloard let me speak first of
all your first guest treated us the
first bit of mouthwash this evening by
claiming that the word Jihad can mean
absolutely anything nonsense when a big
bearded member of hisbah here says calls
for Jihad on the Streets of London then
they are not calling for an inner
personal struggle with the nature of the
Divine they are calling for violence and
anyone who can't recognize that should
be questioned about their own motives
secondly you we've just been treated to
a a monologue about uh casualty figures
in Gaza where do these figures come from
I'll tell you where they come from they
come from Hamas it's quite remarkable to
me that two months after the October the
7th Massacre that two months after the
October the 7th massacres the Israelis
still don't know the precise number of
people murdered on October the 7th
there's a reason for that because it
takes time to work out of that scale one
of the stri one of the Striking you know
I just don't know if either of your
guests are going to allow me a word in
because you are lying and even the
numbers from Israel from the IDF which
are not accredited no you will you know
really interesting hearing somebody who
presents themselves who presents
themselves as a moderate being a
spokesperson for hamz so let me continue
they are Hamas figures they are all
provided by the ministries of Hamas
which is Hamas which is a prescribed
terrorist organization if you want to
reel off Hamas figures then be my guest
but you are not able to mislead the
viewers of piers's show by quoting Hamas
figures at his viewers as if they are
H treated to this
National Community organ do
you where do you think they
get thirdly thirdly I will continue to
speak if it kills you thirdly World War
II it is nonsense that what has been
happening in Gaza has as you said in
this endless list of fallacies that
there has been more bombing in Gaza more
deaths and destruction in Gaza than
during World do you know anything about
World War II do you know anything about
World War II
in alone take one German City take one
German City the destruction was on a
scale totally de Tak
London the number
of let let me ask
question
okay I'm going to come back to let me
ask
one specifically about the it is very
important for your viewers to hear the
following definition the definition of
terrorism is the deliberate targeting of
innocent civilians that is what Hamas
specializes in that is what Hamas did
happening Gaza also is what Israel is is
what Israel is doing terrorism no for
the following reason and again you can
lie about this if you want but do not
expect not to be challenged about it
what the IDF is doing is the same manner
of War as the British army the American
Army and all other armies in the
Civilized World they target terrorists
like Hamas and there are civilian
casualties yes there are but it is not
the aim of the IDF any more than it is
of the British or American Ary armies to
Target civilians and anyone who pretends
otherwise is lying to the public
watching right Douglas final question
before I go back to the two in the
studio here and it's specifically about
the doctor that was on last night
whether he should be allowed to continue
practicing as a GP when he identifies
Hamas as a resistance group wouldn't say
that it committed an act of Terror said
he didn't even believe that there had
been a massacre uh and was also quite
blatantly homophobic amongst other
things well he didn't actually um
dou let me if please please me Douglas
Med the medical
association the medical association is
the one who is assigned to I'm asking
Douglas what he's doing Douglas he's not
a medical doctor I'm asking dougas
opinion Douglas well you don't seem to
be much of an impartial Observer of this
I have to say myself I thought I thought
slightly highly of you before you
started ranting as much as Mr Al andoy
this evening um I'll tell you what I
what I thought of it Piers I think our
country has had enough of people like
your guest last night it's not just that
he's in the NHS why is he in Britain why
do we allow people in Britain to try to
overthrow the state who praise terrorism
members of extremist organ what what has
Britain got from this guy exactly what
benefit have we got from him I mean I
wouldn't want to be an NHS patient going
to him I don't know if any Jews would
particularly want to in Brit I don't
know if very many innocent people would
want to go to this doctor but my
question is not is not just should he be
able to practice I want to know why our
country of Britain has been such a soft
touch for decades that we have Hamas
leaders terrorist spokes people islamist
sympathizers like your guest Mr aland
deloi and now NHS doctors who are
members of of of groups like hisbah that
stand on the Streets of London call for
Jihad call for Muslim armies to arise I
don't think our country benefits
anything from these people I think
people like that should leave we have no
need of them Dr Murray thank you very
much indeed for joining me I appreciate
it let's come back to you gentlemen uh
to wrap this up let me start with you uh
Dr Abes look passions Run High here on
both sides I get that but there have to
be certain points of agreement don't
there and one of the things I find very
hard to deal with like I said at the
start of this debate is when people
simply won't accept what we all saw with
our own eyes because Hamas put it out on
their own videos through their own
social media platforms what happened
October the 7 was a terror attack can we
not agree that I am coming here as a
Palestinian
yes I am not belonging to any faction
and Hamas is not representing the
Palestinian people we have to understand
it it's part of the Palestinian people
it was elected with the free democratic
election in 2006 since that time we
don't have any election we look forward
to have election and we have to respect
the election of the people and the
choice of the people if you in UK
tomorrow to elect any right fanatic
group what do you think the other people
will say to you if they said no we are
they are terrorist or they are not
accepted they are part of the
Palestinian people whether we accept or
not we need to have a new leadership to
have a new election and then it's our
choice to to do it what is happening as
I said it clearly before October 7
October 7 after October 7 will never
lead to any posit way it only aggravates
Bloodshed more animosity more pain more
suffering and more extremism I think I
think you may be right and this has been
my concern about the in my view
increasingly disproportionate response
by Israel is it may have the opposite
effect to what they want it may actually
lead to more radicalism destroying most
of Gaza seems to be what the mission
statement is now I don't see how that
helps the situation at all but I do
understand why they want to try and
elimin Hamas and that's the conundrum
well I'd like to clarify firstly um
Islamic law very clearly says and
there's no difference of opinion on this
for thousand 300 years or even more that
um is impermissible in whatever
situation to Target women children
elderly non-combatants or those not uh
not reservist in an army so uh even the
uh the the Hamas Fighters which were
interviewed on on Israeli TV was the
broadcast was interviewed their
interview uh they said the same thing
that it is PR it is prohibited the the
issue of October the 7th is that there's
a lot there's a big question mark
regarding um what exactly happened I
completely accept let me finish what do
I mean by this I completely accept that
there was um uh Israelis were killed who
were not combatants is reprehensible in
Islamic law and likewise is
reprehensible that non-combatants on the
Palestinian side are killed like for
example an 8-year-old Muhammad alul and
and others in West Bank who was shot by
an Soldier but my point is this right
and here's here's the issue which is
Michael Clark who advises might see on
Sky News talking about Ukraine war he's
a military advisor on channel and also
Channel 4 he described he said that um
Hamas the the operation they actually
lost control of the operation and it
turned into a spontaneous terror attack
I'm quoting him VBA I don't believe a
word of that well well this is what he
says as an my opinion I I know well I'm
I'm giving you an expert
opinionated and then they Glee
in the they didn't in where where did
Hamas do you know that quotation you
seen no Hamas people that day gloating
about it are you watching the videos yes
I did did you watch that Hamas spokesman
you quoted that Hamas spokesman on TV
did you see what he said about the
attack he said that they had there was
no order to to Target civilians what
what many we know they did a general a
general consensus of analyst have shown
that there was looters that came out of
Gaza who were not part of
Hamas
question my simple question is this was
it a terror attack anyone who killed
civilians yeah should be condemned
terror attack reprehensible anyone who
kills C is a criminal was it a terror
attack what October the 7th and we know
I asked you you said what define the
terror attack is that they you target
civili yes okay you target civilians
right so then I I want to ask I answer
that question I want to ask that
question but I just just for the sake of
consistency when the British army
targeted German civilians in World War
II was that a terror attack no because
they were responding to Nazi Germany's
attempt to destroy the world so you're
saying understand the moral so you're
saying that uh because of who they were
fighting it's not a terror attack to
kill to Target civilians that is that
what you're saying you have to wrap this
up I'm ask is that cuz I only I'm saying
there's no moral equivalence between us
defending ourselves against Nazi Germany
who committed a holocaust that killed in
fact they killed 12 million did Britain
launch war on Germany because of the
Jews huh did Britain declare war Germany
because for the sake of Jews Britain
declared war did wion Churchill in his
ultimatum hit did he say stop
persecuting Jews do you know why because
at that time anti-Semitism was so Rife
that people didn't care about the plight
of the Jews it was only afterwards after
they discovered the death camps and so
on so forth don't pretend that the
Allies launched this war for the sake of
of Jews anti-Semitism
anti-Semitism horor of the concentration
camps towards the end of the war to say
we did it to save our democracy and
freedom and the and guess the idea
morans are doing what the pal doing the
pales are the idea there any moral
equivalence is ridiculous but let me
come back one more time before we finish
to my simple question was what happened
on October the 7th a terror attack I'm
I'm and I'm telling you that if you
refuse to call the the bombing the
bombing of B of Dr as a terror attack
then why i' got to leave it there is
that not hypocritical I'm totally fine
to call it a terror attack if you're
willing to call it a terror attack too
let's join each other in condemning both
things including the IDF as what they're
doing as as a teror ATT not believe ID
that's being hypocritical that's being
hypocritical I'm happy to all this as a
terror attack you have to be
consistent
inist you know yesterday I was listening
to the chief of mad and the chief of
shet and he said it's because of the
failure of diplomatic and political
issues this is important and there was
negligence and what can we do now and
that's the most important as a medical
doctor we need to stop the Bloodshed to
go to Serious negotiations to use it
what happened October 7 as an
opportunity to bridge the gap between
Palestinians and Israelis and not to
repeat it again and again I'm got to end
it
there fire people from their jobs
because they have different opinion well
you in England I don't think British GPS
should be coming on National Television
in this country and breaking the law by
publicly supporting and endorsing a
terror group by the way break the law a
criminal offense to support a terror
group in this country yeah of course he
did that last night by what when did he
by saying there were resistance not a
terror group he was talking about
justifi he was talking about
Palestinians in general criminal he was
talking about Palestinian H H talking he
wasn't talk didn't watch the interview
go back and watch leave it for the
police to investigate he to Palestinians
he broke want BR equal rights throughout
all of pal you ask me why that's
why again thanks to Douglas Murray to Dr
AB it's good to see you again thank you
very much Abdullah Al Andi thank you
very much for coming in I appreciate it
s next president zinski is at the white
house right now as he tries to convince
the US to provide more aid for Ukraine
us lawmaker Byron Donald think the us to
stop funding Ukraine and joins me
[Music]
next
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well you know what
I love about talk today we do it all
sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes WR unexpected item in
bagging area I know are we only going to
be trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from Gram was Pres of the Cambridge
Union which is the rubbish version of
being president of the Oxford
Union Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking for a living if you're
walking towards me and you're a vegan
you have a great big orange sticker over
here saying watch out vegan's about
Twitter you sons of can you please
reinstate my account thank you this is a
major Summit President Biden decided
this was important after watching a Tom
Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solv when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call teror group is it
possible to have a
rational talk TV is the only place where
you get the
truth
[Music]
this is talk
TV welcome back to un senson Ukrainian
President Vladimir zelinski came face to
face with us lawmakers in Washington
today as he attempts to win over
Republicans resisting more funding for
his country's war against Putin's Russia
Zin is making last TI effort to save a
$61 billion Aid package well to debate
with the US should keep was Min Port
flow I'm joined by two people who don't
agree with me the conservative talk
radio host Ben Ferguson and the
Republican Congressman Byron Donalds and
I'll start with you Congressman if I may
here's what I don't get all the
resistances is coming from people who
historically would have been absolutely
first in the line to try and stop a
Russian dictator cutting a sthe of
barbaric Invasion through Europe what's
happened to you guys why are you
prepared to let Putin
win first of all Pierce I think that's
the wrong way to even phrase the
question we're not prepared to let
Vladimir Putin win anything the only
thing we're saying is that you have to
actually take care of issues at home
first if you actually do that there'd be
a lot of ability to move Ukrainian Aid
in Congress I have some disagreements in
that number one is there's no
accountability with this money
whatsoever number two Joe Biden has had
no view what this Mission actually is he
wants to cover up his own derelictions
with his disastrous foreign policy that
has led us to this point right now not
just in Ukraine but in my in my view in
other areas around the Globe but House
Republicans and now Senate Republicans
our mission is clear secure our border
get that business done it makes no sense
to give Ukraine upwards of $200 billion
from the American treasury while our
nation is overrun by some number some
estimat million migrants why sense just
do
both listen to be truthful nobody trusts
this Administration they're flagrantly
violating a border security this even
immigration law this is border security
La listen list I agree with you but
what's happening on the border is
completely out of control a dereliction
of Duty by Joe Biden and it's got to be
fixed but America is last time I checked
the number one superpower in the world
the richest and most powerful country on
Earth you're telling me it can't control
its border and at the same time stop a
Russian dictator taking over European
countries really not would not with Joe
Biden as president because the man is
the
master happening in our country it
wouldn't be
Republicans here's our responsibility
right now is to hold the line and make
sure our border is secure because Joe
Biden is such a terrible leader he won't
even take care of f first things first
here in America so if he won't do that
we have to force him to do that and
unfortunately Ukraine is the leverage
point to force him to do it because Joe
Biden let's go back in history let's
remember history Joe Biden saw Russia
amassing troops for 6 months at the
Ukrainian border he did nothing Ukraine
was asking for help during that six
months he did nothing when Russia
invaded Vladimir zalinski was told hey
get on a G5 and if he didn't tell Joe
Biden no give me bullets I'm not looking
for a ride Joe Biden wouldn't even be
talking about sounds like you think we
should have we should have Seer it
sounds to me like you think America
should have been involved a lot earlier
what we should have done is done
everything to make sure an incursion
into Ukraine never occurred and Pierce
let's go back in time was Vladimir Putin
thinking about invading Ukraine of
course but did he do it when Donald
Trump was President he absolutely did
not Joe Biden has led us to where we
Congressman you have to go it's the
final question so you want to wrap
things up in in Ukraine you just give
Putin what he's stolen in terms of land
listen at this point there's going to
have to be a negotiation and a deal
about's happen over there no that's not
what I'm
they need to figure out a negotiation
the number one thing that matters to us
is border security here in take care
America at home then we can talk about
the world care about the Ukrainian
border security so my question is Putin
wants to rewrite the Ukrainian border
and just take vast ways of the country
for himself and you would let him do
that right no I do not want to let him
do that as a matter of fact I want to do
everything I want me personally I want
to do everything possible for Vladimir
Putin to be defeated but I am telling
you
this everything he's Tak pierce the
American voter is demanding that our
security is taken care of first our
borders must be secured that's the
position of the house I know you have B
hold on last minute Pierce last last
thing Pierce all Joe Biden has to do is
undo what he did when he came into
office secure our border then we can
talk about Ukraine until then there's
nothing to talk about all right maybe
Too Late by the then pu may get his
victory and uh and you'll have helped
him anyway I appreciate you joining me
Congressman thank you very much should
we turn to Ben Ferguson thank um Ben uh
I just don't get this I can't let me let
me explain a different way yeah let me
let me explain a little bit different
way there there's two problems here one
there's zero accountability with the
money we're sitting over there right now
there's massive amounts of corruption
with with Ukrainian oligarchs and many
of their families are in five-star
hotels in Warsaw we're paying an insane
amount of money that's not going to the
battlefield so there's a problem here
with accountability that's one of the
questions that that must be answered
before we send more funds the second
problem with this is if you have these
people sininsky and others that are in
charge and they hear from American
foreign policy that they have an
unlimited amount of time with unlimited
dollars coming from the US I'm not sure
they're not going to drag this thing out
because they're all getting rich and
everyone around them with the billions
that are coming into their country
because of the corruption well
documented they're all getting killed
ukrainians true not
the are getting killed they're not the
ones figh
how do you a Republican let me ask you a
question when when uh Saddam Hussein
invaded QA for example did you think it
was right that America went to support
and kick him out I think it was right
the way that we fought that war and we
got them out quickly and we didn't stay
forever on end and that's one you agreed
that when you agreed that when somebody
invaded a sovereign country the right
thing to do even though Kuwait was not a
member of NATO was for American forces
including troops on the ground should
get involved to kick him out right per
there's a difference between
KU over yes because it was a quick
interaction over there's a never ending
date there's a never ending date here
and that's part of I'm not dumb enough
to give an open check and just say to a
country that has massive amounts of
corruption many believe worse than even
Russia when it comes to corruption in
their government here's a blank check
indefinitely for decades on 's another
part of this America exactly what we're
doing
America no offense it's not your tax dos
it's my
taxs fitting the bill let me talk
America's given just about two years of
money so far right and Britain's been
the second biggest donor of money no
troops on the ground like they were in
Kuwait no tanks nothing just giving
money to Ukraine to fund their military
operation so they can try and defeat a
Russian dictator who illegally invaded
their sovereign country just as suddam
Hussein did to qwa two non-nato
countries being defended by America one
you completely endorsed and supported
and one you want to run away from and
let Putin have a victory you're
Republicans Republicans want Russians to
win like this this is where you're wrong
I didn't say run away I said
accountability I want there to be
accountability for this check that I'm
writing as an American taxpayer by the
way with money we don't have that we're
then borrowing and then having to
finance going to corrupt people in
Ukraine
there is a huge difference between these
two scenarios Kuwait was a very
short-term implementation of a process
to win and then it was over that you
could have done 10 Kuwait in the time
frame that you've done one Ukraine which
is an aall mate at best right now going
to feel if you don't give the money
final question and brief answer please
how you going to feel if the money
doesn't get given to Ukraine and Putin
actually defeats Ukraine and then starts
invading other countries near Ukraine
it's not it's not on me that's on Joe
Biden Jo
Jo Biden's
foreign Jo Biden for not securing the
borderer people be the first time in
modern American history where it was the
conservative right that allowed a
Russian dictator to Rampage his way
through Europe and take what he wanted
when you're being staggering Piers Piers
when you're being held hostage by a
president United States of America that
allows for 8 million people to invade
your country in the last year and a half
since he's been president then that is
that and refuses to do his job and this
is what you have to do to hold him to
accountability you do it so if you want
to blame someone don't blame me say I'm
cutting and running I can't stand
Vladimir Putin right I I can't even
travel to Russia if I wanted to in peace
times the reality is this is Joe Biden's
fault that he's not held them
accountable for the money we've already
sent and refuses to ask questions about
the corruption B Ferguson always good to
talk to you thank you for joining on
sens I appreciate it on sens next the
father of a Sandy Hook victim says that
Elon Musk is a sociopath after He
restored the massacre denying conspiracy
theorist Alex Jones to X podcasted zubie
thinks mask is right that I'm a free
speech hypocrite he yours me
[Music]
next we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online we on your smart speaker as well
criminals to useing XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
sport today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an o in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £40
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from
K in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a liit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan she have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegans
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in about three years hundreds and
hundreds of mice in a box which he walks
into a branch of McDonald MC mous man MC
mous man he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got a house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resign yes CU I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a ration car can you
I've asked you two questions should a
mass stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV
it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
[Music]
that welcome back to un sensor on mus
reversal Alex Jones's return to ex-pa
outrage from a grieving father who lost
his son in the tragic sany hood massacre
David wheeler his son Benjamin was the
sixth when he was shot dead along with
20 others has slammed musk's associ
upath the ex-owner previously condemned
Jones for exploiting the death of
children for personal gain politics or
fame and then did a u-turn I'm joined in
the studio by my Pat the rapper
broadcaster podcaster zubie broadcaster
as well talk TV contributor and F lawyer
Paula Ron Adrien I'm the journalist and
former newspaper editor Emily Sheffield
welcome to all of you zubie you think
I'm a flaming hypocrite about Free
Speech because I want Alex Jones to be
continued banned from X why am I a
hypocrite do you support freedom of
speech yes so how do you reconcile that
all free speech Even In America which
has probably the finest protection of
free speech in the world with the first
amendment has a number of things which
are excluded including defamation he was
just found guilty by several courts of
the most egregious defamation
in modern American history and it was
because he targeted for years the poor
families of the Sandy Hook children who
were massacred in that school shooting
and he has not paid a dime to those
families of the 1.2 billion doar he's
supposed to be paying and it's an
absolute disgrace and I agree with what
Elon mus said a year ago which is anyone
that seeks to benefit or gain from the
deaths of children for personal gain or
fame or whatever should not be allowed
on X now he's changed his mind I think
he's been hypocritical not me mhm well
over the past decade I know that for a
fact that Alex Jones has apologized for
that many many times we're talking about
things that he said only when he was
facing Financial Oblivion no he
apologize only when he was actually
being held to account for it no prior to
that no he didn't he never apologized
prior to that yes he did no he didn't
yes he did only when he only when he was
sued no no no he apologized prior to
that I know that is a fact Listen to
listen to his uh Joe Rogan appearance
about four years ago you apologize very
profusely but that was after the
lawsuits were coming in I don't know
about that anyway uh I think if x is
going to be a free speech platform it
needs to be a free speech platform would
you would you let Nick Fuentes back on
yes AB a white supremacist anti antiem
yeah as long as he doesn't break the
rules well those are breaking the rules
no being having views having thoughts in
your head is not against the law the
rules on his show if you say things on
the platform that violate the platform
and if you promote your show and you say
them on your show well if I start
disputing white suprem Stu now in front
of you right and I then tweeted a a link
to the show you'd be happy with that I'm
not saying I would be happy with it but
I wouldn't want you banned from X for
for that really so I could look down the
barrel of his camera and say I think all
black people should be thrown out of
this country watch it watch how they
clip this one well no okay so they some
of them will clip it right and I could
say that and then I could tweet a link
to this show to promote the show and you
would think I should stay on X yes I
would support your right to free spee
wow yeah that's not free speech it's
hate speech no it's fre freedom of
speech specifically exists to protect
views and people espousing views there
are six different criteria excluded
under the First Amendment including
child pornography including defamation
uh including all sorts of things you
can't famously go into a theater and
shout fire for his crowded theater right
but you can there are lots of
restrictions already look there are
people who think that I engage in hate
speech there's people who think that you
engage in hate speech hate speech is a
very subjective it's extraordinarily
subjective term and if everyone anyone
who has ever said anything no anyone can
say anything I don't think you can
directly call to violence right no I
don't think you Alex Jones's words led
to direct violent conf directly no
that's not that's not people were
urinated on the kids graves because they
believe Alex Jones when he said it was a
hoax if someone which he knew was untrue
what do you think is the correct path to
Redemption if someone has said something
that you disagree with do what he did
for that number of years and you have a
$1.2 billion award against you and you
don't pay the fam's one cent declare
yourself bankrupt to avoid it you don't
get to come back onto a social media
platform and start earning money well he
does he's come back on I know Elon Musk
in my view has made a terrible mistake
quick reaction from you two to this I
think it's quite interesting hearing
zuie respond to you without once
referencing responsibilities we're all
very good at identifying my right to
this and my right to that that and when
my right has been abused but what we're
not very good at doing is recognizing
how responsible we have to be when we
are looking at exercising those rights
and clearly he hasn't been responsible
clearly his lack of responsibility has
caused harm and I just wonder what Elon
Musk is hoping to achieve for well okay
Emily is Elon Musk a Force for good or
not on since he he bought Twitter a year
ago well he's not a Force for good for
Twitter itself or X I mean he's recently
told advertisers to f off and I'm afraid
the real cynic and me which I quite like
the real cynic me well it's good but you
know his debt payments and what he
borrowed byx is just must be crippling
him by at this point I think what's I'm
afraid the cynic in me thinks this is
just sort of massive publicity stun
could be it could be and
looking to reverse he does believe in
free speech I believe in free speech I
think there have to be limitations as
the first amendment has but we'll see
how this plays out I think Alex Jones
will live down to every expectation take
a short break come back and discuss
Rwanda
[Music]
next we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online we're on your smart speaker as
well criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn do you know what I
love about sport today we do it all
sunak sella
scon I like David Cameron I don't sort
of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police appr Pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an o in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the IM ount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million1 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin Sullivan is the worst presenter on
talk TV sitting on his fat ass talking
for liit if you're walking towards me
and you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald mcmouse man MC mous
man MC man he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this is important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party
hi kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should aass stay
in power and are they a terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV it's the
only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry and
music for the many I love per we can
agree on
[Music]
that welcome back still with my pack
Emily uh Richie soon that big win
tonight actually after all the Doom
Laden forecast not a single conservative
MP in the end voted against his bill
many abstained but no one voted against
him how big a win is it is it just a
temporary Victory it's 44 so that is a
big win um I'm sort of unfashionable in
my view in that I think he is going to
win this battle um I think there's going
to be a lot of work between now and the
next reading um you know obviously the
writer wanting their amendments those
more to the left one nation don't want
any more amendments if they not they
might want to weaken it a bit but I do
think the right have a long history of
causing a lot of trouble they don't
always go ahead with it and I think I
hope they just keep repeating to them
one year in power is worth five years
here's my point Paul I don't know why he
wants to die on Miss Hill in the end so
a few hundred people get taken to Rwanda
when you've got a much bigger problem
with legal migration numbers going
through the roof up to nearly a million
yeah and and can we just set out what
this absolute fast is quickly if you
don't mind fast is go on the gov.
website have a look at the skilled visas
who who they're looking for who they
need to come and do jobs everybody they
need judges they need barrs they need
solic 5 million people in this country
have given up working cuz we're lazy
workshy we are lazy work population this
isn't about and people are now using as
I always predicted they're using mental
health as an excuse let me come to you
quickly what do we do about immigration
generally the world's got the same
problem immigration in general the rule
of law just needs to be followed and
upheld and enforced I think it's I think
it's that simple you can't just have
people coming in whether this is in the
states people running over the Border in
the hundreds of thousands or this is
same here on Bo in Europe people coming
over on boats the rule of law needs to
be enforced there should be immigration
but it needs to be fair there needs to
be a process and people need to follow
that process I think most people can get
on board with that the trouble is we're
coming up against the rule of law and
that's what the right of the party wants
the ECR pack great to see you all we run
out of time lovely to see you zubie as
always when you're in town please come
we come back that's it for me whatever
you're up to Keep It Uncensored we do
believe in free speech I'm with you on
that zubie just not with Alex
Jones
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
talk today we do it all sunak sella
scun I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the tor's love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster gets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sunak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police appr Pro Palestine that is just
not right you swear an o in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for sadique Khan we're not stopping
until you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
O Sullivan is the worst presenter on
talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC Mouse
man MC mous man he should be easy enough
to catch this guy shouldn't he I mean
he's got a house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film do you